[Applause]
on the steps of the Lindo wing this was
our first glimpse of the princess of
Cambridge asleep in her mother's arms
[Applause]
Prince William helping his wife down the
steps it had been a long day for the
royal couple who'd arrived here 12 hours
earlier careful to wave to the gathered
media and hundreds of well-wishers
giving the worldwide press the pictures
they've been waiting for
earlier in the day her big brother had
also visited his newborn sister
you
Prince George was carried into the Lindo
wing to meet his little sister for the
first time for the past week we'd been
waiting for the announcement and finally
it came we've got a baby come here tell
me so oh you just had the email through
Her Royal Highness the Duchess of
Cambridge was safely delivered of a
daughter 834 this morning the baby
weighs eight pounds three ounces of this
day the second of May in the Year 2015
we welcome double duty a second more of
their Royal Highnesses the Duke and
Duchess of Cambridge the crowds of media
and well-wishers whipped up into a
frenzy
[Applause]
as the world found out the royal family
had welcomed a little princess for those
who'd been loyally waiting outside the
Lindo wing for weeks it was a moment of
celebration I feels like an extension of
my own family I feel this you know
really excited as I've had the baby
myself got the champagne I've got a card
I just hope we're here in a couple years
time the news had first come through
email and Twitter but traditions who
followed with a formal notice placed on
an easel in the forecourt
of Buckingham Palace declaring at 8:34
a.m. the Duchess of Cambridge was safely
delivered of a daughter weighing 8
pounds 3 ounces of both were doing well
[Music]
that's what we wanted my little
granddaughters see a real-life princess
was being born today and that was so
excited cuz she loves princes but now
she's got a real-life princess what's so
exciting
across the country the moment was marked
BT tower in London lit up with the news
while on HMS Lancaster the sailors had
their own message for Big Brother Prince
George as night came Trafalgar Square
was lit up in pink with Tower Bridge
completing the light show the girl had
always been a favorite with the public
and even Prince Charles had suggested he
wanted a granddaughter
now the guessing about names goes on
Alice leads the way as a favorite
Charlotte has been heavily back to three
to one but there's been two big moves
the last few hours
Victoria is now into 61 and Diana is
into ten to one from 14 tours has been a
big move for Diana the Queen seen out in
Yorkshire had clearly got the message
about the arrival of her new
great-granddaughter William and Kate's
families had both been told before the
world got to know like any family the
focus was on getting back home a chance
to get to know their new daughter to see
Prince George and have those final
discussions before telling the world her
name
we annulled Mills Sky News in central
London